boa tarde a todos
é eu vou falar um pouquinho né pra vocês
sobre os aspectos gerais da garantia de
escoamento
eu trabalho no grupo de elevação
artificial e garantia de escoamento do
cepetro é coordenado pelo professor
antonio gambá arte da faculdade de
engenharia mecânica
nós somos em quatro pesquisadores também
temos alunos né de pós graduação porque
o ct petro ele apóia o programa de
ciências e engenharia de petróleo é que
está sob a a coordenação da faculdade de
engenharia mecânica e do instituto de
geociências ambon é também é falar que
essa área é bastante interdisciplinar no
nosso grupo e nós temos químicos
engenheiros químicos engenheiros
mecânicos engenheiros elétricos e
mecatrônicos né então é bastante multi e
interdisciplinar começando é falar o que
primeiro a definição da garantia é o que
é garantia de escoamento é como o
próprio nome fala é garantir né
assegurar que os fluidos que estão ali
no reservatório na rocha pode ser o óleo
água e gás
eles cheguem até a plataforma né e então
desde do reservatório até chegar à
superfície né porque a gente dependendo
da da característica do petróleo é podem
ocorrer em alguns problemas né então a
gente tem que saber quais os problemas
que podem ocorrer
para tentar prevenir nem remediar é é um
ponto o possível o casamento sair dessas
situações né os três principais
problemas que nós estudamos no lg é a
deposição de parafinas né as parafinas
elas são componentes do petróleo nessa
moléculas grandes de carbono e
hidrogênio
a e dependendo de determinadas condições
né de pressão e temperatura elas podem
se depositar na tubulação então aqui
está a tubulação e dependendo de onde
determinadas condições
elas vão se depositando diminuindo
diminuindo é o diâmetro do duto na e
tornando mais difícil escoamento podendo
até mesmo bloquear esse duto aqui
causando seríssimos problemas aí pra
produção outro a outro outro estudo né
que está relacionada à garantia de
escoamento é a formação de emoções né
que é o que é uma emoção né à disposição
são duas fases é imiscíveis uma fase
está dispersa na outra então a formação
de emoções aqui no caso a água é que são
as gotas de água de espécies no meio
óleo né então isso também acaba
aumentando a viscosidade do óleo e
dificulta o escoamento bombeamento de
ltda do fundo do mar até à plataforma e
também é a gente estuda a redução de
atrito nec no caso são pra polidutos dos
derivados recuando a gente fala em
atrito são substâncias - viscosa
snacking são diesel gasolina é
proprietário nona então são escolhidos
por exemplo de um poliduto que sai aqui
da replan e vai até brasília né que leva
o poliduto porque ele leva é os
derivados leva leva gás também na então
por conta das grandes distâncias
às vezes é necessário selecionar alguns
que a gente fala redutores de atrito são
alguns químicos né que que se adicionam
pra para diminuir essa esse atrito então
influi mais facilmente e com menor perda
de de carga né nas tubulações e outra
questão é a redução da viscosidade aí
sim também são para olhos muito viscosos
né então aí é o óleo quando saio muito
pesado é que a gente fala bastante
viscoso quando ele sair do fundo do poço
até a plataforma
às vezes é necessário a gente colocar
também alguns químicos pra
a reduzir reduzir a viscosidade e
garante que ele chegue até a superfície
então aqui eu tenho um esquema é
basicamente do que ocorre a gente tem
aqui o reservatório lá que está uma
determinada temperatura então olhos a 80
graus nesta quente a pressão também é
bastante elevada em torno de 200 quilos
né aqui a gente tem um esquema de um
poço então aqui dentro desse poço é
colocado a questão de bombas para você
colocar o jogar o petróleo para cima né
quando se olha ele percorre toda essa
camada quiné de de de rocha néné e ele
chega aqui já a 60 graus e com uma
pressão menor
aí ele tem todo um trajecto nas linhas
de produção para chegar até a plataforma
a temperatura aqui embaixo a temperatura
da água no fundo do mar é volta de 4
graus
então embora todas essas linhas elas têm
um isolamento térmico e se olha é ele
ele viaja por grandes distâncias nessas
linhas
então ele mesmo com isolamento ele ainda
troca calor e perde né ele chega aqui a
14 graus em uma pressão de 10 quilos uma
pressão baixa então no caso da reposição
das parafinas e se essa queda de
temperatura de 60 para 14 graus é
bastante crítica porque essas parafinas
elas têm uma propriedade chamada de ti
aqui é que a temperatura inicial de
aparecimento de cristais
essa temperatura por volta dependendo do
óleo é 40 43 graus ou seja o óleo vai
baixando a temperatura em que ele saia
60 né e nesse percurso que em algum
momento ele vai passar por essa
temperatura e de 40 quarenta 43° né
porque ele chega a 14 graus
então vou ter formação a cristalização
dessas parafinas e essas para finas
podem depositando nas linhas e da os
problemas de de parada de linha é perda
de carga e diminui a vazão é porque você
está diminuindo o diâmetro do tubo então
você diminui a evasão de produção do
óleo então a gente
é no laboratório a gente busca é busca
entender né
é pra cada determinado a gente trabalha
com amostras de petróleo real mesmo né
ea gente busca entender é estudar nessa
tiac todo o comportamento e físico
químico do petróleo pra tentar é tentar
dar respostas aí as empresas é que nós
temos projetos em colaboração para
responder essas questões é e tentar
evitar que isso ocorra no fundo do mar
caso isso ocorra a neve vai ocorrer né
mas as indústrias elas usam alguns há
alguns métodos para remediar esse tipo
de problema né um deles é o chamado pig
que são raspadores de linha né esse
raspadores eles têm um formato que de um
de um de um canhão mesmo né um a esse
formato aac de de canhão do tamanho do
diâmetro do tubo ele passa raspando
então toda aquela parte sólida que tem
dentro da tubulação na e leva isso para
fora através de linhas de serviço nem a
gente tem as linhas de produção e tem
linhas de serviço no fundo do mar
outro método são os métodos térmicos a
isso ao próprio isolamento também e tem
um sistema gerador de nitrogênio que é
com calor na então é injetado uma unitri
o gênio é uma reação de nitrogênio para
gerar calor nas nessas linhas
e aí então é é você aumenta a
temperatura nessas parafinas elas é
voltam para o estado líquido né você
remove essas esses cristais de parafina
e também tem a parte de injeção de
aditivos químicos que são os inibidores
de parafina e adicionado no óleo ainda
quente e esse aditivo né ll ele mexe na
temperatura do do aparecimento do dos
cristais bom o outro tópico que a gente
estuda é a questão
as emoções na então como já falei emoção
os sons são dois sistemas 22 líquidos
imiscíveis no petróleo então como no
reservatório
lá na rocha também tem água então é
possível que tenha formação ea de
emoções né emoções água em óleo aqui a
gente tem algumas imagens do óleo e umas
pequenas gotas não sei se dá pra ver por
conta da luz mas a gente tem umas
pequenas gotículas de água dispersas no
óleo né então tem o óleo lá embaixo no
reservatório é junto à água com óleo e
ao passar por bombas por válvulas não é
que são situações de elevado
cisalhamento eu promovo a interação
dessas fases e forma emoção e isso é
ruim é ruim porque se o óleo já é de
esposo né a formação de emoções
ele aumenta a minha viscosidade então
aqui a gente tem um gráfico típico de
luz de viscosidade né em função aqui dá
do da taxa de escoamento né ea gente
observa que as quantidades de óleo puro
está aqui embaixo e conforme a gente
aumenta a quantidade de água e aumenta a
minha esposa idade então isso produção é
ruim também né porque eu aumento é
preciso de bombas mais potentes na
primeira qualidade a mais alta para o
bombear o mesmo tanto que se eu tivesse
só o óleo puro então também a gente
estuda no laboratório como evitar a
formação dessas emoções ou também como
quebrar e aqui a gente o que seria o
ideal é ser emoções de óleo em água que
na verdade seriam um gota dispersas de
óleo no meio fluido água ea viscosidade
aí seria é mais baixa mas isso não é o
que ocorre no petróleo
e pra acabar aqui então outro ponto que
a gente estuda é a redução de atrito
néel redução de viscosidade você tem na
tubulação o escoamento né
dois pontos de medida de pressão e esse
delta pm é menor quando a gente coloca
11 mas a perda de carga
você pede menos energia
quando você coloca um agente redutor de
atrito não é tanto para os derivados e o
quanto pro pro petróleo puro agente
adiciona aditivos adutora de viscosidade
está a diminuir essa perda de carga e e
aumentar a vazão ou com menor energia de
bombeamento você você você aumenta é com
menor energia de bombeamento você tenha
a mesma mesma razão
aqui alguns exemplos rapidinho só pra
finalizar da de onde nós tem aplicação
dos redutores de atrito alguns oleoduto
sair no brasil
aqui é uma imagem de uma plataforma p-40
e aqui um navio aliviador que a gente
chama que é o que vem buscar o óleo aqui
na bacia de campos p 38 um dos dutos
dessa plataforma que foi fechado para
manutenção e outro ficou produzindo
então eles fizeram um teste para
adicionar redutores de atrito né e
observar um aumento de quase 20% na
produção por esse único duto também na
companhia logística na espanha é é
ligando esses dois terminais aqui de
terragona barcelona em gerona né a numa
tubulação aí de óleo diesel então
grandes distâncias né então isso é o que
caracteriza o uso de de redutores de de
atrito de viscosidade
eles obtiveram uma redução de atrito de
45%
então é isso é o que tinha pra falar pra
vocês eu trouxe aqui uma duas amostras
de petróleo para vocês verem a questão
só comparativo né da de um óleo pesado e
de óleo leve
então esse aqui na minha esquerda é um
óleo leve
esse aqui não esquerda um é um petróleo
leve é o petróleo típico do pré-sal e
esse aqui é o petróleo já o petróleo
pesado né
se a gente ver ter aqui o frasco dos
dois a gente vê muito mais rapidamente
que esse petróleo aqui ele é bem mais
fluido né do que esse outro então a
gente tenta isto é
estuda é o comportamento as
características pra que é esse petróleo
aqui é tem a mesma a gente consiga ter
uma boa fluência é em relação a esse
outro olha aqui tá então era isso que eu
tinha pra falar pra vocês